so something really interesting happened
as I sat down to film this this review
for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania no
spoilers by the way but something funny
happened Paul read
it was interviewed by Insider and he
revealed something that I think would
have made me like the movie a lot more
in fact one of the problems that I had
with the movie could have been fixed by
this one thing that he revealed and I'm
like
but more on that in just a bit on the
review so first things first
I want this to be very candid very raw I
have some notes here just a little bit
of my thoughts but I want to be you know
I want this to be an honest review first
things first I had a blast with Ant-Man
um it's it's an Ant-Man film right I
mean
the first two weren't the greatest MCU
movies in the world but they were still
a lot of fun and that's that's what
Ant-Man Quantum media is for me now I've
said this it isn't what some other
people say but to me it was the best
Ant-Man movie to me personally now like
to my buddy Greg over at the real
rejects he does not think that I talked
to Brandon Davis over at comicbook.com
he thinks the first ant-man's the best
but I think this one was pretty dang
good as far as Ant-Man movies go so I
ranked this one the highest of the
Ant-Man movies
quick disclaimer um don't let my opinion
influence whether you like a movie or
don't like a movie
um so please if I say some good things
to bad things don't go into the movie
thinking well oh this movie's gonna suck
or it's gonna be fantastic like go to
the movie form your own opinion I don't
ever want to be that person that's like
making people hate movies because I love
movies I love movies and what I'm going
to do is going to start with the good
and go into what I kind of had problems
with so
to start off on the positive side
Ant-Man and the WASP it's just an
awesome movie it's just a fun time like
the experience is just it's good it's
really good it has some really great
parts to it some really great scenes a
really fun movie and I think a lot of
people are going to really enjoy this
film it's got a lot to it it's
funny it's got good humor which I'm
about to talk about it's got good humor
but it's very heartfelt it's touching
there's some great action scenes and
Kang is just insane Jonathan Majors is
perfect it's perfect but one thing I do
want to talk about the humor because
like with Thor love and Thunder
they went too far they didn't find that
sweet spot and and this is something I
think a lot of fans are really going to
like about Ant-Man and the WASP they
found the humor sweet spot to me I
wasn't exhausted with the jokes they
weren't so rapid fire they weren't like
every second and the movie does
kind of stop and tone down
for the more serious parts
so whereas Thor love and thunder went
too far and never really toned down I
think Ant-Man and the WASP found its
Sweet Spot man in the West Point to
Mania found its sweet spot and I think
people are gonna really like the humor
in this movie I did I know I was
laughing at a lot of the jokes
um
and I feel like because there weren't so
many they hit harder if that makes sense
but this you know to me when I say
something is really fun it's awesome the
humor is really a good part of it for me
I thought they were very clever jokes
and I think they found that sweet spot
now
quantumania is the perfect title for
this movie because again no spoilers in
this but they spend
95 of the film in the quantum realm like
it's like they go in and the movie's in
the quantum room right that's the movie
and it's really cool and by the way I am
going to talk a little bit about
post-credit scenes like I said no
spoilers but we're going to talk about
them because they're important so
you we dive deeper into the quantum
realm deeper than we've ever ever been
in the quantum realm and it's really
cool because it's not just like I feel
like we saw the surface level but they
really really just went deeper in this
movie and it's really cool because it
seems to be a very important kind of
universe or a space between universes a
space between time and space and it's
going to be important moving forward I I
think it's going to be important for
King moving forward so they did a really
good job with all of these characters
we're introduced to a ton of new
characters as well some are really
awesome some really funny have really
cool stories and some are just you know
kind of there they're interesting to say
the least but to me this new world
inside of the quantum realm really felt
like Star Wars now I know some people
are like on the fence about that but for
me as a Marvel and a Star Wars fan yes
it is possible to be both I quite
enjoyed it I thought it was really cool
and it wasn't like
hey let's make this like Star Wars it
just kind of felt like that but I
thought it was really cool I thought
there was a a good story with some of
the characters and this kind of Star
Wars like secret underground world
inside of the quantum realm I thought it
was really cool it was really cool
Janet's story
is very interesting and they really
you know they haven't really told that
story to anybody I mean she just got out
of the quantum realm in the last Ant-Man
movie right so and she wasn't
in end game right at least they weren't
fighting they might have been there at
the end in the funeral I can't remember
but uh she has a really cool story and
her character overall is just really
interesting and
just Bravo because it's it's it's really
good it's really good now
she was in there for 30 years right
and she never told anybody but of course
she had interactions with King so the
story between the two of them is really
cool and I think a lot of people are
really going to enjoy it and of course
speaking of King Jonathan majors
a clap for you because
you know when they said he was going to
be king and I saw them all big and buff
for creed I was just like yes like
yes and then when I saw him for the
first time in the mask when the blues
over him you know on the trailers and
the teases and everything like that I
was like this is so freaking cool and he
it's spot on
he's spot on he's an incredible King
like he really is just just spot on he
he's menacing he's big he's but he's the
big bad right he's he's the next Thanos
he's bigger than Thanos he's the guy
that's beat all of the Avengers before
and other timelines in the past whatever
it may be
that's him he's came to conquer and that
he stole the show for me he stole the
show for me I know it's Ant-Man film but
he he really did he stole the show for
me now Paul Rudd obviously is an amazing
Ant-Man and his character was fantastic
as well so the two of them really get
the spotlight on the screen it was it
was quite something and I think fans
Really Gonna Love Jonathan Majors as
king and are really going to be glad
that he is the big bad now
there are a lot of really interesting
and captivating scenes with Kang that I
truly appreciated because it's not just
like hey fight hey technology let's do
all this but there's some like
deep conversations and to me super
captivating even if it's just showing
King with Ant-Man talking or or Janet
going over some of their history it's
just really intense and it really brings
you in and it's just I love everything
about Kang and all of his things now
Modoc
I know everyone has been asking about
um
I quite liked him and I feel kind of
weird
that I'm saying that I liked him because
he is done in a in an interesting way
and many of you have seen him you know
in the trailers and everything like that
I think it was super funny right but at
the same time he has some really great
moments where he's very menacing and you
know is fighting and I think it's
kind of what you would expect from Modoc
I think it's pretty cool he's funny and
he's menacing at the same time which is
really hard to do but I think historian
is Arc in the movie people are gonna
like I really kind of just found him
more funny than anything and I think
that is what some people feared so
if that's what you're fearing yes he is
funny is he you know
Modoc yes
is he designed for killing yes you know
only for killing so you do get that you
get that he's very menacing and he is
you know a villain so
you know hold your breath just a little
bit so make an opinion after you see him
so here's where we get into the little
kind of the the negative side of it I
hate to be negative but I gotta be
honest the overall story is where things
get a little blurred for me on
if it was good and bad you know the
overall story makes sense why Kang needs
Ant-Man you know Ant-Man stuck down
there the whole you know you're gonna do
what I tell you to do or I'm gonna hurt
your family like that all makes sense
but there's a lot of moving parts
to this movie and sometimes it feels
like they're all over the place
the story could have been just a little
bit stronger to me now like I said
there's some great moments there's some
great action scenes there's a there's a
lot of good action scenes and I I was
never bored never bored in the movie at
all like I was entertained the entire
time
but there are a lot of moving parts and
and you know some scenes get lost and
Kang really does deal with the show
um and a lot of these scenes
with these other characters sometimes
don't do a really good job of pulling
you in and kind of making you care if
that makes sense
you know not they don't do a good job at
getting you to invest in some of these
characters and unfortunately one of
these characters is hope I feel like
hope kind of gets
someone gets like sidelined in this
which is weird because it's Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania but I feel like she
was kind of just there
and I'm bummed about that because I do
like her as a character and I really
liked you know how her and and Scotland
were in Ant-Man and the WASP the first
one so unfortunately
she doesn't really get that much
Spotlight here
um she has some few good scenes but most
of the scenes that she's in are kind of
forgettable or they're mixed with other
scenes that are more focused on other
characters and she's like I said she's
kind of just there you know for the most
part the spotlight is on Ant-Man Kang
Janet you know Hank Pym does get his
moments however he does get his moments
um and he has some cool scenes he isn't
sidelined as much as hope in fact I
would say he's a little bit more
important to the movie Than Hope
actually probably considerably more
important which is also weird because
again it's Ant-Man and the WASP but not
you know the original Ant-Man and the
original wasp which is kind of what
they're trying to do here uh as well I
know a lot of people are gonna like that
hope wasn't really the center of
attention
um like nearly as much as the other
characters but uh Hank isn't at the
center a lot really as well like I said
it really does come down to Ant-Man Kang
Janet and Cassie
I will say
Cassie's great Catherine Newton did an
incredible job at playing the role of
Cassie and the character is very
interesting it's very interesting she
has some great moments in the movie A
lot of great moments in the movie A lot
of great father-daughter moments and her
character just in general is interesting
and you root for a character and you do
get invested in the relationship with
Scott and his daughter Cassie it's she's
funny she's genuinely charismatic and
serious when she needs to be like you
feel the gravity of some of the serious
scenes that she's in with Kang and that
she's in with Scott I wanted more of her
she in and only because I feel like she
was so great I actually think she got
the amount of time that she deserved she
really did she's like Scott's driving
force for the movie right a father
trying to protect his daughter a father
trying to get you know his daughter out
of the quantum realm out of danger it
really is the driving force for him and
this goes back to hope it's not so much
for hope you know he's it's real he's
really focused on Cassie now I say that
she got enough because of the timing of
the movie she is great and I did want
more of her and this is kind of where I
have some of my issues with the movie
the story again it's fine
it's nothing special but it could have
been made into a bigger deal
a lot of the story doesn't pull you in
and make you feel connected to a lot of
the characters
it does a fine job with you know the
main characters like I said but
sadly this is where my issue with the
movie comes in the story is fine
it's nothing too special which is the
problem
it's nothing too special especially when
it was marketed that's a really big
movie and I thought it was going to be a
really big movie the story doesn't do a
great job at pulling you in for some
characters and make you feel connected
to a lot of them sadly hope is one of
those characters
but the movie needed to be I think about
40 minutes longer this movie is just a
little bit over two hours it needs to be
longer and I know some people are tired
of like three hour movies but this movie
genuinely needed to be longer I think it
should be a two hour two hour and 40
minute movie and it wasn't
we needed more for the story for Kang
and here's my biggest complaint about
the movie
we needed more King
we needed a lot more King and we
specifically needed more of Kang
fighting I wanted more of a
demonstration of his powers and we got a
little bit of it but there's a lot of
scenes where he's kind of just talking
and they're really good don't get me
wrong they're really good but I needed
more
of him fighting you don't get much of
him fighting and that's my biggest
complaint in all honesty about the movie
it didn't necessarily ruin the movie for
me but it kept it from being a really
great movie and it did kind of let me
down now it's crazy like I said as Paul
Rudd recently revealed that they had to
actually cut
some scenes of him and Kang fighting
because they were too violent and I'm
like
what that's my complaint that's like my
biggest complaint about the movie is
that I wanted more fighting because the
trailers look so promising for these
killer fights and don't get me wrong
like I said there there are but I needed
more I wanted it to be longer the movie
needed to be longer so
that's kind of my biggest complaint
about the movie and
some people might think it's okay and
some people might agree with me which is
fine again go to the movie and form your
own opinion now like I said
the final battle to me was kind of a
letdown because of how short it was and
just how it wasn't
too much involved with can't I mean it
was involved with King but it could have
been more of Kang showcasing his true
power and I'm not going to say anymore
because it's a spoiler but you'll see
what I mean and I'm curious to hear
everybody's thoughts we'll do a spoiler
talk uh after it's already out now the
post-credit scenes okay
they're important the first one is more
important than the second so the mid
credit scene
no spoilers again but it's I was I stood
up and I clapped and I and I yelled and
I was like freaking awesome it's awesome
it really is and it's really it's really
important now
here's kind of a funny thing
after I got out of the movie met with my
friend Eman he was there ran into him on
the carpet we were you know just talking
about the movie and he said and I was
like that post credit and he was like
the post-credits scene should not be
better than the movie and he felt like
it was now it was insane it was super
super cool and I do agree with him at
where it shouldn't be but I don't think
it was better the entire movie however
it's definitely one of the highlights of
the movie so stick around for that
post-credits scene
um and the second one
without going into any spoilers it's not
as groundbreaking as the mid-credit
scene however it's still extremely
exciting and it gives us a look into the
future just a little bit so stick around
for both of those I truly did love both
of the post-credit scenes so I think
overall
a lot of people are going to really
enjoy this movie I think people are
probably going to have some of the same
qualms that I had with it and
yeah I'm just excited to hear what
everybody thinks about it now if I had
to rate it because I know everybody's
been asking me to rate it probably a
seven out of 10.
I think it's like a good c
um C plus like if they could have fixed
a few things and just made the movie a
little bit longer and gave me more Kang
I would have been really really happy
they it kind of showcased this and
marketed it as a huge Avengers level
movie and I just feel like we didn't get
that it wasn't on that level it's still
very much just an Ant-Man movie which I
was fine with I still had a lot of fun
with it I still thought it was pretty
awesome uh is it one of the greatest
Marvel movies ever no but I think a lot
of people are gonna think it's better
the Multiverse of Madness Thor love and
thunder you know etc
etc but go to the movie see it for
yourself be excited going into it have
fun because it's just a fun experience
in general and when I do the spoiler
talk let's talk about how you all think
or what you all thought about the movie
I'm really excited to hear everybody's
reactions to it so thank you all so much
for watching this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you like Marvel DC and the
other pop culture content be sure to
subscribe to the Channel all I talk
about every day uh be sure to like the
video and you can always follow me on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf